what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the fall of X and picking
up with Colossus and X-Force now for
those of you guys who were unfamiliar
with the X-Force team this is basically
like the Black Ops Team for the X-Men
right like they get their hands dirty
and do all kinds of crazy covert stuff
but what they're talking about here is
kind of in preparation for the Hellfire
Gala so this takes place alongside
everything we've covered so far but it's
also sort of separate from it at the
same time and Colossus makes a point in
saying due to the extremely sensitive
diplomatic situation that we find
ourselves in as a nation and due to the
terroristic Behavior Beast is up to on
the global stage X-Force will stay off
site maintaining a satellite presence
only at this year's Hellfire Gala now a
couple things to know here again for
those of you guys who are kind of
joining us when he's referring to the
Diplomatic situation remember once all
the mutants basically took off to
krakowa it created a lot of fear and
trepidation for the human race right
because a lot of people saw it as the
mutant population building up an army
and that's why you saw all these little
pot Shots by governmental organizations
or by groups like orcas and so on and so
forth trying to find some way to
infiltrate the mutant population or
destroy the mutant population now the
whole situation with beast that's
actually covered in the Wolverine Comics
which we need to finish but basically
because they're kind of like the Black
Ops Team they're effectively just
watching and so of course they have like
cameras and different things like that
and Colossus even goes as far as to say
that in the unlikely event that
something were to happen that they'll
all only ever be seconds away right
they'll be Incredibly Close and they'll
be able to respond accordingly and so
what this does is it transitions to
Cyclops kind of walking this sort of
reef area right the cliffsides of
krakowa and then planting one of their
teleportation Gates remember those are
the gates that allow you to enter in and
out of krakowa no matter where you are
in the universe so long as you are a
mutant somebody with the the mutant Gene
now of course things transpire exactly
the way you would expect them to right
Deadpool is just kind of like nah man
I'm gonna go check out the dance I'm
gonna go hang out over here in uh at the
Hellfire Gala and then Domino actually
leaves now there's a reason why she does
this right there's a really really cool
reason right she's like I've got
something to focus on it's more
important than this but I promise you it
needs to be done then you switch back
over to Colossus and then Colossus at
the Hellfire Gala itself basically just
kind of wishes around a little drink and
kind of enjoys himself and then he's
ultimately met by Xavier now none of
this seems overly important but if you
understand what's going on with Colossus
right now in the X-Force Comics it's
wildly important and I will explain it
so of course Xavier kind of visits him
and the two of them sort of talk a
little bit and so on and so forth and
just kind of muse right and Colossus
informs him that like X-Force is
basically on station in case anything
pops off they can respond accordingly so
on and so forth then you transition to
the Savage
and you pick up with Domino and what
domino does is she talks about how
Colossus had kind of left her
breadcrumbs so to speak that he wanted
her to come over here to check out the
secret quote unquote that he had buried
here this is where he resided this is
where they had a lot of the crops and
stuff that they would use for the
various medicines and so on and so forth
what she finds here is a painting of
Kayla now Kayla was a mutant that
resided with Colossus and would help him
like tend the farms and all that kind of
stuff and in fact Colossus killed her
like he killed Kayla and we'll talk
about why again here in a little bit but
before any of this can really come to
Bear suddenly the orcas strike takes
place right so the Hellfire Gala is
attacked by the forces of orcas Nimrod
is basically annihilating and defeating
all the Omega Level mutants right all of
some of the most powerful mutants and
the response of Colossus is basically to
tell everybody to stand down now this is
the important thing right we get this
kind of monologue where we're told this
was not part of the plan an
unanticipated plot twist a broken
narrative he has no words no plan until
the writer finds a way to salvage the
operation and that's when he says
everybody stand down and he says there
are many here who are more than capable
of handling this so stand down right
then you jump to Domino and is Domino's
making her way through the field she
finds this large area that looks
recently Disturbed and where flowers are
just now starting to bloom there as she
starts to dig she finds the body of
Kayla and she makes this statement this
isn't you but you did it all the same
and this can be interpreted in a couple
different ways right like it's not in
the nature of Colossus to do something
this terrible what in the world happened
that led to him killing this girl but at
the same time there's actually a
different meaning behind that again you
know we'll explain it don't worry I'm
not going to leave you guys hanging but
ultimately x-23 initially goes to
respawn right Laura Kinney leaves
X-Force to go respond to the Hellfire
guy Allah and she stopped by Colossus
right who tells her I have a gate that's
ready and waiting for us to access so we
can get directly into the conflict the
entirety of the X-Force team Omega Red
or at least those who are here they all
basically respond and go running into
the gate in the middle of all this
though Sage the kind of brains of the
team is contacted by Domino who tells
her Colossus cannot be trusted and where
Sage goes to tell her like he's leading
us into the fight her response is
whatever he tells you to do do not do it
but regardless of this virtually
everybody runs in right you've got Laura
Kinney you've got kid Omega you've got
Omega Red and Colossus only for all of
them to be ambushed by Mikhail Rasputin
the brother of Colossus now here's the
thing right let's explain what in the
world is going on here because you guys
are all right this is not normal for
Colossus to betray the X-Men he's part
of The Quiet Council he's part of the
governing body that's designed to ensure
that the mutant population remains safe
and so on and so forth all those
different things what had happened in
X-Force issue number 24 is Mikhail
Rasputin one of the most powerful
mutants in Marvel Comics and a mortal
enemy of Colossus and even the X-Men had
come into contact or really attained the
services of a guy called the chronicler
and the chronicler is a reality warping
mutant with the ability to write down
anything and whatever he writes down
becomes true and so the idea was to
basically write down what Colossus will
and will not do in effect Colossus has
been a sleeper agent for Mikhail
Rasputin for quite some time when he was
brought on as part of the Kauai Council
he was a sleeper agent and nobody knew
the difference nobody was any the wiser
now Mikhail is not working alongside
orcas he had his own plants and that's
why Colossus says our plans have changed
everything has changed and I don't know
where we go from here it's cool this is
really amazing moment because he's
basically an unwitting betrayer of the
X-Men with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end if you need
to get caught up on fall of X make sure
you click this link to the playlist and
I will catch you all later
peace